يُطلق على الفندق اسم Grand Petine باللغة
الإيطالية ، وهذا يعني أن
معظم الضيوف قد أتوا إلى هنا
لأنه يقع على بعد 30 مترًا من الشاطئ ،
نحن على البحر الأسود الجميل ،
دعنا نذهب وسأريك ما حدث
بعد أن أصاب الصاروخ أمنه
التقطت الكاميرات الضربة الصاروخية كما
حدث ، هذه هي المرة الأولى
التي يشاهدها الجمهور هذه بأقصى
سرعة ثم قمنا بإبطائها يمكنك
رؤية الصاروخ منخفضًا ومباشرًا من
اتجاه البحر الأسود حيث
كانت روسيا تطلق صاروخها  الهجمات على أوديسا ،
لذلك كان هناك هجوم مباشر من
صاروخ مباشرة إلى فندقك ولم يصب أحد
أو يموت
الحمد لله لم يصب أحد هنا
لأنه عادة في هذا المكان
كان هناك دائمًا أطفال وأولياء
فندقه البكر على شاطئ البحر اعتاد أن
يكون  المفضل لدى السائحين والسياسيين الروس ،
لقد أنفقوا أموالًا جيدة هنا
في السنوات التي سبقت الحرب ، لا
يريد الاعتراف بذلك ، لكنه كان هو نفسه
عضوًا في الحزب الموالي لروسيا هنا
هذا
مدمر
هل تلوم الجنود الروس في بوتين ،
ما رأيك في الروس قبل
ذلك
منذ عام 2014 ، شعرت أنهم أوغاد
ولكنني لم أرغب في تصديق أن
2014 كان العام الذي غزت فيه روسيا
شبه جزيرة القرم وضمتها 2022 ، وتعرضت بقية
أوكرانيا للهجوم
لماذا تعتقد أن الروس
ضربوا هذا الفندق؟
كنت
تسمح لهم بالعودة فقط إذا
تم أسرهم وأجبروا على إعادة البناء